for too long defenses lives on a diet of
smoke and mirrors hollowed out
formations and fantasy efficiency
savings while in the last few years a
threat from states have started to
increase
and right now russia is the most direct
and pressing threat to europe to our
allies and to these shores
i'm serious when i say there is a very
real danger that russia will lash out
against wider europe
and that in these days of long-range
missiles and stealth distance is no
protection
as the chief of general staff so
correctly pointed out this morning the
threat has changed
and as the prime minister and his fellow
leaders are addressing madrid today so
must our response
russia is not our only problem
an assertive china ready to china's
rules-based system and democracy
terrorism on the march right across
africa iranian nuclear ambitions to date
still unresolved
the threat is growing
and is global and is multi-domain
and it's now time to signal that peace
dividend is over and investment needs to
continue to grow
before it becomes too late to address
the resurgent threat and the lessons
learned in ukraine it's time to mobilize
be ready and to be relevant